pour en débattre nous sommes en direct
avec théo lobry démocrate animateurs du
groupe bernie sanders france bonsoir à
vous théo lobry merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés nicolas conc'air mandé
républicaine sauveur 6 france
merci à vous au nicolas conc'air d'être
avec nous également lors il y avait déjà
pas mal de tension avant mais alors là
ça chauffe encore plus entre donald
trump et les médias américains qu'il
accuse tout de même de lui avoir volé sa
victoire est ce que c'est un petit peu
voilà tout match pour reprendre une
expression américaine de ceux déclarés
volés
cette élection nicholas cronk heures
c'est pas un peu trop quand même alors
déjà est important de rappeler quand on
est dans un système constitutionnel aux
états unis que cette constitution et à
2791 et c'est bien elle qui tapinent les
rênes à l'article si vous l'avez vous
dire que deux sections 3 paragraphe 1
qui va dire que donc c'est au vote et
qui va déterminer l'issue du scrutin
donc nécessaire de le voir aller
jusqu'au bout du dépouillement et que
l'issue l'officialisation la
certification de ces résultats ne sera
donnée que par les grands électeurs
la réunion des grands électeurs
y'a aucun moment indiqué que c'est à cnn
de prononcer qui est le résultat qui est
résultat acquis le vainqueur de ce
scrutin
pour moi on assiste vraiment une espèce
de coup de force par un coup d'état
meetic et nicolas singer alors c'est
vrai que c'est pas que cnn qui a annoncé
ses résultats c'est souvent voilà le
fruit de la société de presse
c'est cette tradition aux états unis
foxnews a quand même suivi
on a un peu perdu nicolas scamps caire
on va aller se frotter aux lobry t on
aubry a tout de même vous comprenez
qu'elle ça fasse un petit peu désordre
parce que c'est vrai qu'on rappelle
lorsque nous a rappelé poteau m'abonner
avant en 2000 il a fallu attendre le
recomptage total des voix contestées par
libérer de l'enjeu bush pour avoir le
le vrai vainqueur les résultats
officiels est ce que on n'a pas un petit
peu pardonnez moi l'expression sackey
donald trump parce que tout simplement
on ne l'aimé pas beaucoup dans les
médias américains
ah non pas du tout je crois pas enfin la
situation entre 2000 et 2020 n'est pas
du tout comparable déjà rien que par le
fait qu'en 2000 c'est plutôt la floride
avec quelques centaines de voix qui pose
problème
là on a quand même 4 aux états qui sont
à plus de entre 10 et 40 mille de voie
de plus pour joe biden enfin un trucage
ou annoncé trop tôt les résultats c'est
simplement mensonger de dire ça de la
part des républicains du président on
aurait pu le dire dans le cas des aides
de 2000 forcément puisque c'était entre
200 et 1000 voix qui séparait dans un
seul état là on a quatre états avec plus
de 10000 à 40 mille voix d'écart pour
jack layton il faut arrêter la
plaisanterie en 2016
donald trump s'est pas offusqué du fait
que soit cnn fox news et l'associatif
plus qu'il le déclare vainqueur alors il
faudrait peut-être pas abuser non plus
hors en 2020 en racontant tout et
n'importe quoi nicolas soit ouvert je
sais pas si vous avez eu le temps de
tout écouter vous étiez en train de vous
réinstaller c'est vrai que voilà votre
contradicteur théo lobry nous disait que
c'était pas vraiment le même cap en 2000
c'est vrai que là il ya eu plusieurs
milliers dizaines de milliers de voix
d'écart dans plusieurs états différents
est-ce que donald trump ne fait pas un
petit peu mauvais perdant sur ce coup là
on pourra peut-être en 2000 face à al
gore les bouches il y avait une annonce
prématurée par cnn qui avaient tous
afficher au grand écran dans la carrière
de l'annonce que gore avait remporté
l'élection
l'histoire nous a montré que ce n'était
pas tout à fait le cas c'est allé deux
fois la cour suprême il est des recours
juridiques qui ont abouti et qui rend
tranché en faveur de bush
vingt ans plus tard nous voilà
maintenant dans une situation où il ya
des cas très spécifique dans chacun des
états der compte qu'ils vont se faire
parce qu'on est dans une marge d'erreur
vraiment très telus au wisconsin au
michigan en géorgie et d'autres cas de
soupçons de fraude qui vont être
tu es au niveau des tribunaux des cours
fédérales ou à la cour suprême si
nécessaire
je rappelle que la dendre d'état qui est
très scrutées qui à la pennsylvanie
il ya une modification du code électoral
de manière unilatérale
trois jours avant l'élection pour
faciliter le vote par correspondance
avec des conditions qui sont tout à fait
anticonstitutionnelle donc la laque ou
la cour suprême va s'en saisir et il va
y avoir tout un process juridique qui
est menée par de nombreux avocats
théo lobry vous êtes inquiet justement
par une éventuelle saisie de la cour
suprême on rappelle que donald trump a
nommé voilà un tiers de cette cour
suprême à renouveler ça fait six juges
conservateurs sur sur neuf est ce que ça
peut porter à conséquence sur cette
élection selon vous non parce que ça
n'arrivera jamais que la cour suprême
des juges ce qui est en train de se
passer au niveau du vote pour la simple
et bonne raison que la cour suprême ne
voudra pas être plongé dans la chute de
donald trump et qu'elle a une vocation
être supérieures aux intérêts personnels
de tel ou tel candidat mais pour suprême
si jamais et ce qui n'arrivera pas
déjugé le vote est allé en faveur donald
trump
c'est ce qu'on appellera un coup d'état
nicolas conc'air justement cette cour
suprême vous vous avez la même analyse
que côté all aubry bout j'ai absolument
immonde et dans ce sens là on dise avant
d dans le sang se disant que c'est la
plus haute juridiction aux états unis la
cour suprême est la plus haute confiance
auprès des citoyens américains
d'où le fait que goldman est maintenu
dans son état actuel de neuf juges
contrairement à des volontés des
démocrates qui joue pas forcément cartes
sur table dans le fait qu'il pourrait un
peu saturé les cours comme on dit donc
augmenter le nombre là n'est pas la
question
tout ça pour dire que quand bien même il
ya des juges qui ont été nommés dans le
droit par donald trump président en
exercice jusqu'au 21 janvier prochain à
minima il y laisser ses juges l'aï zobi
cela de droit constitutionnel il
respecte les institutions n'ya pas c'est
pas une cour partisane maintenant ils
vont apprécier l'ensemble de ces
éléments à la douleur du droit et donc
du coup il ya déjà des recours qui ont
été faits sur la peine s'il
l'ensemble des bulletins qui sont
arrivés après la fin du scrutin ont été
mis de côté donc selon sont
comptabilisés de manière distincte de
manière à ce que lorsqu'il y aura un
jugement qui sera qui sera arrêtée on
pourra savoir si ces bulletins sont ou
légaux ou frauduleux et doivent ne pas
être comptabilisée en tout cas les
républicains eux clairement affirmé
aujourd'hui qu'il y à des fraudes et
irrégularités des bottes de logiciels
des bulletins comptés après la date
butoir ou encore des morts qui votent
théo lobry ces accusations pour on voit
le bon fond on ricane est tout
simplement vous les exclus et totalement
non mais alors qu'il ya un petit peu de
fraude ça arrive en fait à tous les
scrutins
toutes les études qui sont sérieuses à
ce sujet qui ont été menées au cours des
différentes dernières élections des
dernières décennies elles mesurent la
fraude à moins de 0 1% donc en fait
c'est absolument rien alors il ya
quelques vidéos qui circulent sur
youtube dont on ne sait absolument pas
la provenance on ne sait pas l'année
elles sont parfois trafic et puisque l
on était ce qu'on appelle des bouquets
c'est à dire qu'elles ont été vérifiés
et on a conclu à ce que c'était de cette
news donc ça en fait ça c'est pas une
preuve
et puis admettons que ces vins vidéo qui
traînent sur youtube soit une preuve ça
représente quoi peut-être 200 500
bulletins de vote
on est à plus de 40 milles en
pennsylvanie si je dis pas de bêtises et
on est à plus de 10000 en géorgie dont
qui sont des états qui sont qui peut
serrer qui sont les derniers à avoir
donné le le global donnant est entre
guillemets donc il faut arrêter un petit
peu avec tout ça les états unis ce n'est
pas un pays du tiers-monde eux sans
manquer de respect au tiers-monde
c'est un pays la première puissance
mondiale et qui est capable de mener à
bien une élection faut arrêter la
plaisanterie alors là la question parce
qu'il ya eu quelque chose d'inédit dans
cette élection qui vous avez dans pas
échapper plus de 90 millions de votes
par correspondance on sait que ces votes
peuvent susciter la fraude et que c'est
vrai que les états unis toute puissance
qui sont n'était pas forcément préparés
à autant
de vote par correspondance nicolas
conc'air vous vous êtes justement
particulièrement inquiets sont ces votes
par correspondance puisque c'était le
leitmotiv de trump 1 que selon lui elle
favoriserait les fraudes mais silva il a
dit bien avant l'élection pour amener sa
niveau de la france il est important de
rappeler que le vote par correspondance
a été arrêté par un arrêt depuis 1975 la
récente de centristes de poniatowski
donc justement parce qu'il y avait des
soupçons de dubal attardé sting comme
montesa aux états unis qui consiste à
faire utiliser un peu la faiblesse de
certains tiers pour aller voter en leur
nom il ya effectivement beaucoup de
suspicion et de malversations liées à ce
canal là en revanche pour ce qui va être
de l'intégrité des élections ça vous
tient peut-être pas à coeur vous mais
moi en tant qu'américain républicain je
suis absolument mais confiant et attaché
à ses institutions démocratiques et que
toute fraude quel que soit le nom la
quantité nécessite d'être investiguer
jugé c'est un crime fédéral aux états
unis peut-être à vos yeux salies rien
pour moi c'est très important on encourt
cinq ans de prison dix mille euros
d'amendé
c'est très très significatif et 6000 et
en confiance dans ça vous laisseriez
aisément refaire le compte de chacun de
ces bulletins juste pour garantir la
fiabilité et l'intégrité de ces
élections
il en va de la légitimité de cette
élection et du mandat des quatre années
à venir
théo lobry la réponse on voit pas de
souci on veut ils peuvent recompter
autant qu'ils veulent toute façon les
écarts sont trop quand on ne basculera
pas de plus 40 villes et plus 50 mille
parfois à eux moins dix milles entre
guillemets au pire on à la marge on va
retrouver peut-être 200 bulletins 300
bulletins de plus pour train pour 200
bulletins de 300 bulletins de plus pour
joe biden pour ce qui est par contre
effectivement des fraudes qui sont à la
marge et qui sont absolument qu'ils ne
représentent absolument rien sur
l'échelle des 150 millions de personnes
qui ont voté
effectivement faut investiguer tenir les
coupables c'est un crime fédéral comme
ça a été très bien rappelé par
l'intervenant républicains voient là
mais c'est comme dans toute élection en
france aussi à des investigations
quand il ya une fraude électorale et
jusqu'à présent on n'a jamais on n'a
jamais eu
de soucis ou de ou de problèmes parce
qu'en fait les candidats en confiance et
les candidats même quand ils sont dans
une position où c'est serré c'était le
cas aux états unis
les périodes précédentes comme al gore
en 2000 en fait concède enfin accepte la
défaite et et font passer l'intérêt de
la nation au dessus de leurs intérêts
personnels et on voit bien qu est ce que
fait donald trump c'est d'essayer d'en
c'était tout le monde dans sa chute
sauf que ça s'arrêtera très vite puisque
la cour suprême malgré le fait qu'elle
soit à majorité conservatrice ne ne se
permettra pas de tomber dans le même
trou que donald trump et il vaudrait
mieux d'ailleurs que donald trump
s'arrête là accepte sa défaite et à la
rigueur qui retente le coup en 2024 à
nicolas ce con car justement c'est
intéressant ce maudit hôtel aubry ce
sera le mot de la fin sur la stratégie
de donald trump c'est vrai que là on le
voit à la poster des tweets ans il
renomme des membres de son gouvernement
comme finalement si ça allait continuer
s'il était repartir pour un tour si
j'ose dire ce que c'est c'est la bonne
stratégie il faudrait pas quitter la
table et peut-être comme le dit théo
lobry revenir tout simplement dans
quatre ans c'est très intéressant est
très symptomatique d'un partisan de
bernie sanders qui lui s'est retiré à
plusieurs reprises lors des primaires
démocrates justement pour laisser passer
qui s'est fait voler justement les
primaires démocrates
justement parce qu'il y avait des
affaires un peu l'establishment a été
privilégié donc on leur a volé sa
campagne donc très bon perdant deux fois
de suite c'est honorable ça vous adore
mais bon en termes de combativité donald
trump sera là et jusqu'au bout et tous
les recours juridiques qu'il a à sa
disposition
si deuxième mandat il n'ya pas il y aura
toujours un boulevard peut-être 2024 il
aura athènes malte global d'aujourd'hui
mais il ya également un grand chantier
qui est pour assurer la liberté
d'expression aux états unis on voit bien
cet acharnement médiatique dont il a été
victime depuis le début de son mandat ou
la nécessité d'être vilipendée insulté
lui sa famille son électorat et quand on
voit la mobilisation malgré tout ça avec
tout ce qu'on a pu dire sur trump 70
millions personnes qui se dépassent pour
glisser un bulletin c'est absolument
faramineux et il ya forcément donc un
boulevard à saisir pour recréer un
espace de liberté
et pour sortir un peu de ces géants de
la tech qui ont une position
monopolistique de la silicon valley et
recrée donc des nouveaux réseaux donc on
le voit aussi bien sur la chaîne de
télévision haut à network par l'air qui
commence à monter en popularité et qui
vont vraiment permettre de contrecarrer
toutes ces censures tout ce shadow ban
tout ce qu'à une seule culture qui peut
exister sur les réseaux de milan que je
ne citerai pas notre cas je pense que
c'est vraiment une belle belle
inspiration
merci nicolas se conquiert et théo lobry
d'avoir été avec nous